Our conscience: it's what helps us choose right from wrong,...
...good from bad, and fair trade bananas from the rest.
So to convince shoppers that All Good fair trade bananas were the way to go,...
...we became their inner voice, literally.
We used a new sound device called the audio spotlight.
Unlike a regular speaker, the audio spotlight emits a narrow high frequency beam of sound.
Because its audio is focused, it's heard by you and you alone.
Like that voice in your head.
We positioned this device over a floor sticker in a store,...
...and when shoppers stood on it they heard their own private message.
No one else heard a thing.
Here's how it worked.
Hi, you can hear me, can't you?
You're the only one.
Is it cool?
Look around, no one else can.
See?
Know who I am?
I'm that inner voice.
I want to talk to you about something.
Fair trade.
Look at them all, those bananas in front of you; which should you buy?
I know, and you do too.
They're all good bananas.
They're the only fair trade ones.
So now you know which ones to choose, make a good choice.
Man, it was so weird but it was real cool.
It sounded like there was a voice actually in my head.
I can't really explain it, it was awesome.
Yeah, how did they do it?
I know, it freaked me out a little bit, it felt like someone was inside my head.
Can I go on it again?
Over two weeks, thousands of shoppers listened to their conscience...
...and All Good sales went up a hundred and thirty percent,...
...which was all good.